there was a
incident between johnny and amber
here during that trip amber was telling
him that he was a
washed-up actor
he was going to die a lonely fat lonely
old man then you heard uh you hit me
with a can you hear johnny say you hit
me with a can and then he came down the
steps
and amber was behind him
and she had a bottle in her hand it was
removed and there was a brief pause at
the moment uh i think of initial shock
or
uncertainty of why you know that we were
there i think
neither johnny nor amber knew that we
were there
um he proceeded
to
walked back to the john deere
and
she
again walked he was sitting in the seat
amber came up to him and was asking him
to come back in the house that she was
sorry please come back in the house
um and
uh
he didn't come out of the seat and she
was hugging and kissing him and i love
you i love you she was telling him i
loved you um he didn't react
joni sat there um eventually uh got out
of the john deere
um and proceeded to
start to walk away at that time amber
started to grab at him and his shirt
and and trying to pull him back to the
house
just basically viciously trying to pull
him back and get him back to the house
and and and yelling at him and at that
point i i was between them and uh felt
it was
best and i was getting worried about
what was going to happen and it was best
that um
[Music]
i removed him from the
situation and so
cj took
amber back to the house and i
walked johnny over to the cafe which was
basically 30 seconds away from from the
house because it was the only place i
could take him to at the time what did
you observe when you went back to the
cafe with mr dan
i when we went back to the cafe he had a
mark across the bridge of his nose um i
got a bag of ice to put on his on it so
that it wouldn't swell
um just to make sure that it wasn't
bleeding and i
he walked over to the
love seat at the cafe and he
laid down and
went to sleep and cj came back over and
i asked cj to stay there for the
remainder of the evening for the
remainder of the morning
and i left cj inside the cafe and i left
johnny on the couch
when did you next see miss heard
that that morning i saw i saw her that
morning how close were you to ms heard
when you interacted with her the next
morning
uh conversation
um
in in a couple feet away
when you saw her how did she appear
they had guests leaving and
it was
kind of a normal morning
going down to the beach to see the
guests leave
what if any makeup was miss heard
wearing
again i'm not sure she
if she wore makeup on the island if it
was it was very natural looking
what if any injuries did you observe on
misheard
i didn't observe any
what if any injuries did you observe on
mr dap
the
the marking across the bridge of his
nose
as a result of the work that you
performed did you form any opinions
with respect to ms heard i did
what were those opinions
i uh
the results of ms herd's evaluation
supported two diagnoses borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder
one is
a diagnosis
a diagnosis is a way that we essentially
that psychologist psychiatrist anybody
in the mental health field
thinks about a disorder it helps us to
communicate a set of symptoms that a
person is experiencing and along with
that set of symptoms it it tells other
professionals a lot about how those
symptoms might have developed how that
person might behave perceive the world
it also drives treatment the real
purpose is to determine what sort of
interventions will be most effective for
the person
what
conclusions were you able to draw about
miss herd's sophistication from her
testing
well from her testing and from her
presentation she's she was very likable
but her testing in particular um
showed that she approached it in a
manner that
remember i told you about those those
scales that are pretty neat
she approached it in a manner that very
clearly minimized any psychological
dysfunction
not just that but really presented
herself a free of any problems and she
did so in a way that was very um
very sophisticated not obvious
by responding to questions that most
people
might not notice
would were
trying to detect that and when you first
saw amber heard she was crying red eyed
and was not making eye contact with you
correct correct
and you asked her a few questions and it
was quite clear that she did not want to
speak to the police is that correct
correct
now amber heard was visibly upset
so she would look down sometimes she
would look up at you when she spoke but
was back and forth correct
what was ever heard wearing that mag
i don't recall
what
hairstyle did amber heard have that
night
i don't recall
now
when was the first time you were asked
to provide details of the events of may
21 2016
i don't recall
do you recall providing your testimony
at a deposition
in
july of 2016.
is that the first time you were asked to
provide any details of what your
recollection was of the events of may 21
2016.
okay and that was roughly two months
later is that correct
correct
and how many shifts had you worked in
that two-month period
uh i'm not aware i don't know
how many calls had you answered in those
two months
i don't know that number
how many of those calls were domestic
violence calls in those two months
i don't know that number
and
if you
saw any signs of injury on amber heard
or even just damage to property
would you have been duty-bound to make a
report
correct
now
your
recollection is that there was no damage
to the the flat you searched the entire
flat and there was no damage broken
glass or anything out of the ordinary
would you agree
correct
did you
see anything did you observe anything
out of the ordinary during this
particular call that you answered at the
penthouse on may 21 2016.
i did not
when you left
that call when you got back into that
elevator do you recall what you were
thinking
i remember being impressed by the the
penthouse how big and beautiful it was
yes
but anything else
no nothing
and just so we can stay on that for a
minute you did not
you had not heard of amber heard at the
time of this report right on may 21 2016
correct
but you didn't know that johnny depp was
an actor correct
correct
and you didn't know that that was johnny
depp's penthouse when you reported that
correct
correct
you